[Musik]
Corona nachgehakt
weltweit explodieren die
Infektionszahlen auch in Deutschland
geht nach einer Phase der Entspannung
die Inzidenz steil nach oben klar das
liegt daran dass Omikron viel
ansteckender ist als bisherige Varianten
aber
Omegon scheint auch weniger krankmachend
und weniger tödlich zu sein ist das
alles nur eine gute oder eine schlechte
Nachricht darüber möchte ich heute mit
Professor Klaus Stöhr sprechen er war
viele Jahre Leiter des influencer
Programms der
Weltgesundheitsorganisation
und arbeitete anschließend in der
Impfstoff Entwicklung beim Schweizer
Arzneimittel Konzern Novartis herzlich
willkommen bei Corona nachgehakt schönen
Tag ja unser Thema heute unikorn
Albtraum oder Ausweg aus der Pandemie
wie sehen Sie das
also auf jeden Fall ist es eine Realität
der mit der wir uns arrangieren müssen
wenn man sich anschaut wie sich die
Viren in den letzten
wann entwickelt haben ist es eindeutige
deutlicher Schritt Richtung ende der
Pandemie das Virus hat sich an den
Menschen schon besser angepasst es wird
vielleicht nicht mehr so tief in der
Lunge sich vermehren das sind der andere
Organe betroffen vielleicht nur die Nase
oder der die Schleimhaut mehr in dem im
Nasen-Rachenraum die Inkubationszeit
verkürzt sich Alltag sind eigentlich
Zeichen der Anpassung an den Menschen
und das ist der richtige Ansatz dann
wenn man näher zum Ende der Pandemie
kommen will der Datenlage in Deutschland
ist leider sehr schlecht aber wir haben
die Zahlen aus anderen Ländern in denen
Omikron schon länger aktiv und dominant
ist beginnt wir vielleicht mal in
Südafrika wo man das Virus zumindest als
erstes entdeckt hat wie sieht es da aus
also entspanne in der Provinz in dem
Krankenhaus dort wo die ersten Fälle
aufgetreten sind auch wo der Pik als
erstes zu verzeichnen war gehen die
Zahlen schon wieder zurück eindeutig
gibt es dort auch mildere Verläufe
mannhatten 70 prozentig geringere Chance
an der Omikron Variante zu versterben
oder auf die Intensivstation zu kommen
als im Vergleich zur Delta Variante die
dass man im Krankenhaus bleiben muss hat
meine 50% geringere Chance und
interessanterweise weil das ist auch
wichtig für uns 65% der Coroner Fälle
durch Omegon die dort festgestellt
worden in den Krankenhäusern in der
letzten Zeit waren Zufallsbefund oder
waren also Mensch ins Krankenhaus
gekommen getestet die hatten vielleicht
einen Blinddarmdurchbruch und Beinbruch
oder in Schussverletzung und da wurde
dann
Corona festgestellt dass zeigt wie
heftig das Virus in der Population
zirkuliert aber auch mit welchen relativ
im Vergleich zu Delta beschränkten
Auswirkungen und der Pikten Welt gesehen
hatten der in Südafrika vor Weihnachten
der eigentlich jedes Jahr dort bei den
Atemwegserkrankungen Auftritt der lässt
auch jetzt nach und die Omikron Welle
scheint dort signifikant ab zu flachen
jetzt kann man ja aus vielerlei Gründen
sagen die Situation in Südafrika ist
eine andere als in Deutschland also
blicken wir nach Großbritannien auch da
ist Omikron schon dominant und dann
hören wir von 200000 Ansteckungen pro
Tag das klingt zunächst einmal sehr
beunruhigend ja das sind sehr viele
Infektion aber Infektion heißt ja nicht
gleich krank sein heißt ja auch nicht
leicht sofort seid Virus in der Lage zu
sein weiterzugeben und so ist die
Situation auch dort vor allen Dingen in
England wo die
wo mehr Fälle auftreten hat in
Schottland bei unseren anderen
Landesbereich und was man dort sieht
sind sehr viele Fälle 57 Jagd zehnmal
mehr Fehler als in Deutschland wären
unregistrierter viele milde und
asymptomatische aber ins Fanta Weise
verhält sich die Linie der der die
Grafik für Menschen auf dem
Intensivstation sind horizontal aber da
gibt es keine Zunahme der Gruppe ein
Haken Professor wir haben nämlich da
eine Grafik vorbereitet die würde ich da
an der Stelle gerne zeigen das ist die
Situation in London und wir haben hier
da die vier Kurven jeweils gemessen am
Höchststand im Winter vor einem Jahr und
da sieht man das was sie schon
angesprochen haben zunächst einmal die
hellblaue Linie der sieht man jetzt in
den letzten Tagen dieser extreme Anstieg
der Fälle darunter die dunkelgrüne
dunkelblaue Linie das sind die Zahl der
hospitalisierten infizierten da gibt es
einen Anstieg der ist zu beobachten aber
die Zahlen sind doch deutlich deutlich
geringer als im Winter vor einem Jahr
und besonders interessant die beiden
Linien ganz unten in orange was ist die
Zahl der Patienten die in den
Krankenhäusern künstlich beatmet werden
und in rot die Linie der Toten und da
sieht man im Prinzip keine Veränderung
bei den beatmeten und bei den Toten im
letzten halben Jahr obwohl die Zahl der
Fälle so dramatisch angestiegen ist
jetzt ich hatte sie unterbrochen aber
die Grafik wollte ich doch noch anderen
ja dasselbe repräsentativ es gibt eine
große Studie aus England die das genau
auch so viel größere Landesteile belegt
es gibt ein 25% Diegese vermindertes
Risiko wenn man ein unikon erkrankt
überhaupt ins Krankenhaus zu kommen und
ein um 40% vermindertes Risiko auch dort
zu bleiben und wenn man vorher eine
Infektion hatte dann reduziert sich
dieses Risiko sogar auf 50 bzw 60% also
es gibt sehr viele Fälle es gibt auch
eine
Zunahme der Person hier ins Krankenhaus
kommen aber wenn sie ins Krankenhaus
kommen dann brauchen Sie in der Regel
eine Beatmung dann brauchen die nicht
diese Intensivpflege das heißt also für
uns auch in Deutschland dass die
Situation sich ähnlich entwickeln wird
das der Druck auf die Hospitäler zunimmt
aber mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht
dieser Druck auf die Intensivstation
Thailänder würde ich noch gerne
ansprechen zuletzt mal die USA eine
Millionen Neuinfektionen pro Tag und
dann auch Dänemark eine Inzidenz von
über 2000 das sind ja schon zahlen die
wir bisher überhaupt nicht in Betracht
gezogen haben
ja wenn ich dann sehne mich noch ich
habe im Oktober 2020 vorher gesagt dass
die Inzidenzen gut über 80 bis 100 gehen
werden und da hat man sich hier
erschreckte an den Mund gepasst aber das
ist tatsächlich jetzt so die Zelle
verlaufen viel milder es ist nicht nur
ein umschalten erfolgt was diese Schere
betrifft zwischen den zunehmenden
Infektionen und positiv befunden und der
horizontal weiter verlaufenden Anzahl
der Personen die in die
auf die Intensivstation kommt hat auch
ein gewisses umschalten im Kopf
stattgefunden die Realisierung dass man
mit dem Virus leben muss dass man in so
einer Situation auch sehr gut
weiterkommt wenn man sich da drauf
einstellt wenn man die Kontakt
Beschränkung anpasst wenn man die
Quarantäne anpasst wenn man natürlich
weiter impft und für die fürs Boostern
wird also die Realität hat auch hier
beim Denken eingezogen dass man in die
Normalität zurück muss trotzdem würde
ich noch mal um die Beurteilung der
Gesamtsituation bitten wenn ein Virus
ansteckende aber gleichzeitig weniger
krankmachend ist dann kann das im
Endergebnis sowohl zum mehr als auch zu
weniger Kanten und Toten führen also
müssen wir jetzt in Deutschland mit
einer extremen Belastung unseres
Gesundheitssystems und mit mehr Toten
rechnen oder können wir eher mit der
Entspannung rechnen
er soll sich auf drei Ebenen anschauen
die Ergebnis die wie viel positiv
Befunde wird geben also wie beim Testen
wenn man weiter so testet wird es sehr
viele neue Fälle geben zweifelsohne wird
sich das in der in der Inzidenz um 300
500/800 bewegen können die zweite Zahl
die man sie anschauen ist wie viel
Personen kommen in die Hospitäler auch
diese Zahl wird zu nehmen zum Glück wird
es hier nicht so schwere Verläufe geben
dann kann also die Krankheit viel besser
hier in den Griff bekommen behandeln die
dritte Position die man sich anschauen
muss Intensivstation und Todesfälle hier
wird es eine
horizontale Bewegung geben oder
vielleicht sogar eine Abnahme unter
Umständen trotz dieser Zunahme der
Inzidenzen und das sind eigentlich alles
gute Nachrichten das Virus passt sich an
es vermehrt sich mehr im Nasen und
Rachenraum weniger in der Lunge dadurch
wird die Infektion milder die
Inkubationszeit verkürzt sich und ähnelt
nun langsam der der anderen schon
endemisch bekannten Coronavirus die
liegt so zwischen zwei und fünf Tagen
die Viruslast wird höchstwahrscheinlich
ich auch verändern alt das sind ganz
normale Anpassungsprozesse die diese Tür
Viren wenn sie auf den Menschen
überspringen durchmachen man darf auch
nicht vergessen alle Viren die wir als
Menschen kennen kommen vom Tier sind in
den letzten Jahrhunderten
Jahrtausenden irgendwann auf den
Menschen übergesprungen mussten dich
doll anpassen das haben wir bei den
Influenzaviren so gesehen bei vielen
anderen wir hämorrhagischen Fieber und
auch und durch Moskitos übertragene
Infektionserregern die passen sich an
und verändern sich es ist für das Virus
nachträglich seinen wird so schnell zu
töten denn dann wird das Virus nicht
mehr weitergegeben was ist eine
revolutionäre Situation die so schon
vorhersagbar war und wie ich gehe mal
einfach davon aus dass es weiterhin
viele Varianten geben wird vom
Coronavirus aber dass sich diese
Anpassung schrittweise noch weiter
fortsetzt man darf aber jetzt nicht
erwarten dass wir irgendwann mal ein
Virus geht hat gar keine Erkrankung mal
verursacht und dann alle Menschen immun
und dir mit der gar nichts mehr merken
es hat ein Gleichgewicht sein man muss
sich das so vorstellen wie bei der
Influenza oder bei den anderen
Atemwegserkrankung Adenoviren renovieren
renovieren mit der promovieren
Paramyxoviren gibt es ja viele und da
hat sich auch über die Jahrzehnte
Jahrtausende so einen equilibrium
eingestellt was heißt das jetzt in der
Konsequenz müssen wir aus Furcht vor
Omikron die Corona Maßnahmen weiter
verschärfen oder können wir sagen nein
das ist nicht nötig wir können
vielleicht sogar die eine oder andere
Maßnahme aufheben also Tempera jetzt für
den Winter muss man weiter die Kontakte
reduzieren es gibt die aha Regel sollte
noch weiter aufrechterhalten werden gibt
noch über drei Millionen Menschen über
60 Jahre die sehr schwer erkranken
können auch mit unikon das ist völlig
fraglos also das ist noch notwendig aber
man sollte jetzt schon Dinge die möglich
sind umändern warum soll man Personen
die geimpften und Kontakt hatten mit
einem
asymptomatischen positiven Fall warm
soll man die einfach an Penis schicken
warum kann man nicht Personen die
erkrankt sind erst schon dann frei
testen lassen wenn die zwei oder drei
Tage negativ haben warum soll man nicht
Personen die leichte ungeimpften aber
Kontakt hat mit der Person sie krank ist
in dich auch durch frei testen er aus
der Quarantäne hatte das kann man alles
anfassen aber im Frühjahr im April
spätestens im Mai wird die Situation
erreicht sein wo die Infekt würde
Infektionsdruck nachlässt signifikant
geringer wird dann wird es sehr sehr
ruhig werden über den Sommer dass wir
sie hat allerdings weiter zu polieren in
der südlichen Hemisphäre viel
dramatischer als bei uns und im nächsten
Winter muss man dann überlegen wie bei
der Influenza möchte man den über
60-Jährigen in impfangebot machen das
wird aus meines aus meinem Blickwinkel
großen Sinn ergeben der oben dann jedes
Jahr diese Atemwegserkrankungen im
Winter besser abzupuffern dann in 2 kann
doch nicht sein wird werden wir sehen
wenn das Virus sich so anpasst wie die
anderen schon bekannten vier endemischen
Coronavirus von denen niemand etwas
gehört hat vor zwei Jahren dann wird
gleich noch gar keine Impfung notwendig
sein aber das bleibt abzuwarten der
würde ich gerne ein Haken sie haben
vorgeschlagen die Impfpflicht noch mal
zu überdenken Warum
ja inflicted ein sehr starkes
Instrumente und es hat seine Wirkung
aber auch Nebenwirkungen aber es ist
wichtig zu evaluieren ob es Alternativen
gibt was hat eine höhere Effizienz in
geringerem Kollateralschaden kann man
jetzt tatsächlich vor dem Ende dieses
Winters sehr schnell so eine Impfpflicht
umsetzen dass sie auch wirksam ist man
muss sie erst durch die natürlich durch
die Bundesregierung bringen durch die
entsprechenden gesetzgebende Organe dann
muss man noch impfen dann ist es gleich
schon früher und warum soll man alle
impfen wenn man vielleicht
übersichtlicher in mit einer Impfpflicht
viel besser erreichte dort die
Krankheitslast reduziert also ich
plädiere nicht dass man die Impfpflicht
vergesst sondern da dafür dass man die
Alternativen dazu auch evaluiert und
auch vielleicht angepasste Impfpflicht
Konzepte wie z.b. nur die über
60-Jährigen oder bestimmte Altersgruppen
Berufsgruppen in solche temporäre in
Pflicht hineinzuziehen man muss auch
daran denken irgendwann wird die Impfung
vielleicht gar nicht mehr notwendig sein
und warum muss man sich dann jetzt durch
diese sehr stark die Gesellschaft
belasten auch sozialer Kollateralschaden
verursachende Aktion zwingen wenn
vielleicht Alternativen da sind oder nur
kurzzeitig so eine Maßnahme notwendig
ist bisher führte die Strategie in
Deutschland darauf möglichst viele
Ansteckungen zu verhindern um die Toten
und um die Belastung des
Gesundheitssystems zu minimieren wenn
wir jetzt diese Entwicklung betrachten
bei unbekannt ist das noch die richtige
Strategie oder könnte man allmählich um
Steuern auf so einen Kurs wie man in der
Schweiz oder vielleicht in
Großbritannien fährt also
Bohrung der Corona Maßnahmen eine quasi
kontrollierte Durchseuchung der
Bevölkerung ja vielleicht nennt man
nicht kontrollierte Durchseuchung Sonne
die Realisation dass das Virus permanent
zirkuliert Revier Nendaz in unser
Fachsprache der Übergang von der
Containment also von der ersten Phase
der Pandemie wo man dieses Virus
Zirkulation versucht zu minimieren zu
sogenannten mitigation wo man die
Krankheit Auswirkungen hat versucht zu
minimieren das ist jetzt ein ganz normal
richtiger Schritt in Africa in Südafrika
hat man die
Quarantäne und Kontakt Beschränkung
schon völlig reingelassen einfach weil
er die Russo
ubiquitär zirkuliert in Frankreich hat
mir lässt man auch die Personen die
Kontakt hatten und geimpft waren gar
nicht mehr in Quarantäne also wir müssen
diese Schritte jetzt sukzessive gehen
aber nicht linker Straßengraben rechter
Straßengraben sondern man muss das
eskalierendes ist noch Winter es wäre
jetzt richtig sich an die Situation
anzupassen die Quarantäne verändern die
Kontakt Beschränkung auch neue Konzepte
für die Gesundheitsämter die sind ja
immer noch beschäftigt mit der Kontakt
Nachverfolgung im großen Umfang und mit
der Berichterstattung der Zahlen aber
die Zahlen Ansicht diese Inzidenzen
haben eigentlich für die angewandte
Seuchenbekämpfung aus meinem Blickwinkel
gar keine Bedeutung mehr wichtiger wäre
es zu wissen wie viel geimpft und und
Games die liegen tatsächlich auf der
Intensivstation welche Alter sind sozial
Gruppen sind hast wie kann man die
Infektion der in bestimmten Gruppen
reduzieren da und das nehme ich ein
vielleicht noch sagen dir das Ansatz
lose Testen von Kindern dreimal pro
Woche da habe ich noch keine Zahlen
gesehen wie viel Fälle man dort damit
tatsächlich verhindern kann mir wäre es
wichtiger dass man versucht die impf
Motivation weiter zu erhöhen und drüber
nachzudenken wie man die Maßnahmen
adäquat anpassen kann an die sich
verändernde Pandemie Situationen das war
Korona nachgehakt heute mit Professor
Klaus Stöhr herzlichen Dank und bei
Ihnen zu Hause bedanke ich mich für
Interesse bleiben Sie gesund
[Musik]